From NPR, this is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Amidst the confusion and chaos of the COVID-19 pandemic, many of us have sought out a long-trusted lifeline. The local newspaper. Reporters venturing out to hospitals, to remote areas, to nursing homes, they tell us what's happening in the world in our country and in our own communities. They let us track the spread of disease, the
这里是NPR的《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在新冠疫情的混乱与迷茫中，我们许多人都寻求了一条长期受信赖的生命线——当地报纸。记者们冒险前往医院、偏远地区和疗养院，向我们讲述这个国家、世界以及我们自己的社区正在发生的事情。他们让我们追踪疾病的传播、
availability of ICU beds, the well-being of our neighbors. It should come as no surprise that in the past couple of months, print an online local newspaper readership has soared. Yet at this time, when the value of local journalism is most evident, as readers are inhaling article after article, newspapers are not thriving. They are collapsing. Well, it is a difficult day for journalism in Cleveland. Today, the plain dealer newsroom went from 38 employees down to 16. Well, North Dakota's two largest newspapers
重症监护室（ICU）床位的可用情况以及邻居们的健康状况。毫无疑问，在过去的几个月里，印刷版和在线地方报纸的读者数量急剧飙升。然而，正当地方新闻的价值最明显、读者们如饥似渴地阅读一篇又一篇报道的时候，报纸并没有蓬勃发展，它们正在崩溃。对克利夫兰的新闻界来说，这真是艰难的一天。今天，《诚实人报》的新闻编辑室员工从38人减少到了16人。北达科他州的两大报纸
are taking steps to trim costs amid the coronavirus outbreak. COVID-19 vaporized the papers advertising. Revenue is down more than 30%. The 98 of the company's 375 employees have inferlode or had their hours cut back. The problem is only going to grow. Advertising revenue, which newspapers rely on, is vanishing as business is shutter and people practice social distancing. For many publications, COVID-19 might be the final nail in the coffin.
正采取措施在冠状病毒疫情期间削减成本。新冠疫情让报纸的广告收入化为乌有，收入下降了30%以上。该公司375名员工中有98人被迫休无薪假或被削减工时。这个问题只会越来越严重。随着企业关门和人们保持社交距离，报纸赖以生存的广告收入正在消失。对许多出版物来说，新冠疫情可能是棺材板上的最后一颗钉子。
For decades, the financial health of many newspapers has been precarious, in good economic times, and bad. If you talk to people who don't subscribe to their local paper, you can see why the industry is in dire straits. Here are some Denver residents we spoke with. I've never subscribed to a local publication. I usually just get the free ones like Westwood, the free one that comes out in the little red bins
几十年来，无论经济形势好坏，许多报纸的财务状况一直岌岌可危。如果你跟那些不订阅当地报纸的人聊聊，你就会明白为什么这个行业陷入了绝境。以下是我们采访的一些丹佛居民。我从来没订过地方刊物。我通常只拿免费的，比如《韦斯特伍德》，就是丹佛各地那些红色小箱子里发的那种免费报纸。太喜欢上面的优惠券了。我买报纸就是为了优惠券。而且我的意思是，脸书（Facebook）上什么都有，所以……
all over Denver. Love the coupons. What I wanted the paper for is the coupons. And I mean Facebook has everything, so. Their logic and that of millions of Americans is that there are lots of options to pay little or nothing to read the news. There are blogs, there's Facebook, there's Twitter. Why subscribe if you don't have time to read the paper? If you think the paper is biased, if you want to save money.
他们的逻辑以及数百万美国人的逻辑是，有很多选择可以让人花很少甚至不花钱就能读到新闻。有博客，有脸书，有推特。既然没时间读报纸，为什么要订阅呢？如果你觉得报纸有偏见，如果你想省钱。
All of this makes rational sense. Except, it doesn't. That's because newspapers are not like most things we buy. If we decide not to buy an espresso machine, we save money. But if we decide not to pay for a police department, we might save money in the short run, but end up paying much more in the long run. Most of us treat newspapers like consumer products,
这一切在理性上都说得通。除了，它根本说不通。这是因为报纸不像我们买的大多数东西。如果我们决定不买浓缩咖啡机，我们就省了钱。但如果我们决定不为警察局出资，我们在短期内可能会省下钱，但从长远来看，最终要付出多得多的代价。我们大多数人都把报纸当作消费品，
but new research suggests they might be more like police departments. This week on Hidden Brain, we bring back an episode from 2018 that's acutely relevant right now. We ask who bears the cost when nobody wants to pay. In the winter of 2009, a few denware-based reporters headed to a region of mountains and canyons called the Roan Plateau. Just a few years earlier, it was the site of an oil and gas boom. But that boom had turned into a bust. So, we were going up the room plateau where many fewer workers were employed and looking at how people were struggling to try to keep things going and make ends meet.
但新的研究表明，它们可能更像警察局。本周的《隐藏的大脑》节目中，我们重播了一集2018年的节目，这集节目与当下高度相关。我们探讨的是，当没有人愿意付钱时，究竟是谁在承担成本？2009年冬天，几位常驻丹佛的记者前往一个名为罗恩高原的山脉和峡谷地区。就在几年前，这里还是一个石油和天然气开采热潮的发生地。但那场热潮已经变成了萧条。所以，我们前往罗恩高原，当时那里的就业工人少了很多，去看看人们是如何挣扎着维持生计的。
Laura Frank was an investigative reporter for the Rocky Mountain News. We were riding up with some of the oil and gas workers trying to get up the plateau. It had rained and so the dirt road going up the plateau had turned really into kind of a muddy mess. And here we are sliding in this pickup truck, trying to get up the plateau, when suddenly we see these semi-trucks coming down the same road and not sure what kind of control they were under. And I'm thinking, why am I risking my life for a newspaper that's about to close? A newspaper that was about to close. Laura was worried about the rocky. Several weeks earlier, a
劳拉·弗兰克是《落基山新闻报》的调查记者。我们和一些油气工人一起坐车上高原，试图上去。当时下过雨，所以上高原的土路基本上变成了一片泥泞的烂摊子。我们坐着这辆皮卡车打滑，试图开上高原时，突然看到几辆半挂卡车顺着同一条路开下来，也不知道它们能不能控制得住。当时我在想，我为什么要为了一个即将倒闭的报社去冒着生命危险？一份即将倒闭的报纸。劳拉当时很担心《落基山新闻报》。几周前，一个
balding man in a suit had stood in the middle of her newsroom. Reporters and editors clustered around in a circle. Many had their arms crossed. Some scribbled in notebooks. This is a newsroom, so I doubt I actually need to give you the headline. It must have been probably already known, but we're going to announce just in the next few minutes that we're going to put the Rocky Mountain news up for sale. Laura had listened to the announcement with dismay. The newspaper was going to either be sold in the next 30 days or it would be closed. And if you remember what was happening in December of 2008, we knew we were on the verge either of a great recession or the next great depression. So I was pretty sure that they probably weren't going to sell the newspaper over the holidays
秃顶、穿西装的男人站在她新闻编辑室的中央。记者和编辑们围成了一个圈。许多人双臂交叉，有些人则在笔记本上涂涂画画。这里是新闻编辑室，所以我猜我其实不需要给你们念头条了。这大概大家已经知道了，但我们将在接下来的几分钟内宣布，我们要把《落基山新闻报》挂牌出售。劳拉怀着沮丧的心情听取了这个宣布。这家报纸要么在未来30天内售出，要么就会关门。如果你还记得2008年12月发生的事情，我们知道我们当时正处于大萧条或下一次大衰退的边缘。所以我相当确信，在那个没人知道经济前景究竟会怎样的假期期间，
in 30 days when no one knew what the economic outlook was really going to be. Days after her reporting trip to the Rome Plateau, Laura got word about her fate at the Rocky. The corporate managers had flown in and you know you're in a big and sophisticated newsroom. We knew they had landed, people had sources at the airport, we knew they were there and we pretty much knew what they were going to say. The same balding man in a suit gathered journalists around him. Tomorrow will be the final edition of the Rocky Mountain Dews. Certainly not good news for any of you and certainly not good news for Denver. Just want to make sure and say it. Certainly nothing you did, you all did everything right.
他们大概不会在30天内把报纸卖出去。在罗恩高原的采访之旅结束几天后，劳拉得知了她在《落基山新闻报》的命运。公司高管们乘飞机赶来了，你知道，身处一个大而成熟的新闻编辑室，我们知道他们已经降落了，有人在机场有消息源，我们知道他们来了，我们也大致猜到他们会说什么。同一个秃顶、穿西装的男人把记者们召集在身边。明天将是《落基山新闻报》的最后一版。对你们所有人来说这当然不是好消息，对丹佛来说也绝对不是好消息。我只是想确保把这句话说出来。这绝对不是你们的错，你们所有人都做对了所有事。
But while you were out doing your part, the business model and the economy changed, and the Rocky became a victim of that. Denver can't support two newspapers any longer, especially two morning full distribution, general interest newspapers, it just can't happen. It was very hard to leave that night. I remember sitting at my desk for a very long time, just sitting there and not, you know, I was finished. There was nothing more I could do, but I didn't want to walk out of there.
但正当你们在外尽职尽责时，商业模式和经济却发生了变化，而《落基山新闻报》成了其中的牺牲品。丹佛再也无法支撑两家报纸了，尤其是两家早间全发行、面向大众的综合类报纸，这根本不可能发生。那天晚上离开的时候非常艰难。我记得我在办公桌前坐了很久，只是坐在那里，没有，你知道的，我结束了。我无能为力，但我就是不想从那里走出去。
The story about the oil and gas past that Laura had spent weeks working on, it was scheduled to run that Saturday. The rocky closed one day earlier, on Friday. When Laura left the rocky newsroom for the last time, she was concerned about her own future, but she was even was concerned about her own future, but she was even more concerned about the work she had left undone. I had all of these stacks of documents on my desk at the Rocky Mountain News, each representing some issue that I thought needed investigating.
劳拉花了好几周时间调查的关于油气过往的报道，原定于那个星期六见报。《落基山新闻报》提前一天，也就是周五倒闭了。当劳拉最后一次离开《落基山新闻报》的新闻编辑室时，她既担心自己的未来，甚至更担心她自己未来的同时，她甚至更担心她尚未完成的工作。《落基山新闻报》的办公桌上堆满了各种文件，每一份都代表着一个我认为需要调查的问题。
One of those issues was electronics waste or e-waste. The very week that the Rocky Mountain News closed that last week of February in 2009, federal agents had raided an electronics recycler. That raid came after a dramatic investigation by 60 minutes. Tonight we're going to take you to one of the most toxic places on Earth, a place that government officials and gangsters don't want you to see. The 60-minute investigation alleged this company had sent e-waste to China where people were dipping parts and acid and burning them over open flames to get little bits of gold and
其中一个问题是电子垃圾，即“洋垃圾”。就在《落基山新闻报》倒闭的那一周——2009年2月的最后一周，联邦特工突击搜查了一家电子产品回收公司。这次突击搜查是在《60分钟》节目进行了一次引人注目的调查之后进行的。今晚我们将带大家去地球上毒性最大 A 的地方之一，一个政府官员和匪徒不愿让你看到的地方。《60分钟》的调查称，这家公司将电子垃圾运往中国，人们在那里把零件浸入酸液中，并在明火上焚烧，以提取微量的金和其他金属。
other metals. And they were exposing the village to dangerous levels of lead. In fact, 70% of the kids in that village had dangerous levels of lead in their blood. So here you had an ongoing federal investigation into the role of Colorado company allegedly played in endangering kids in a foreign nation. And my newspaper was shutting down.
他们让这个村庄暴露在危险浓度的铅污染之中。事实上，那个村庄里70%的孩子血液中的铅含量都达到了危险水平。所以，当时正有一项联邦调查，针对的是一家总部位于科罗拉多州的公司涉嫌在外国危害儿童的行为。而我的报社却要倒闭了。
We couldn't investigate, but the worst thing was no other local media had the capacity to investigate it either. What happens when a newspaper isn't around to dig into stories of corruption and malfeasance? Like millions of people around the country, denver's residents decided not to subscribe to their local newspaper for what seemed like perfectly good reasons. They were busy, the news was depressing, the paper was expensive, but these rational choices as consumers turned out to have serious consequences for them as taxpayers and citizens. Stay with us. There's a graph that I saw years ago that stood out to me so much that I now have it pinned to the wall in my office.
我们无法继续调查，但最糟糕的是，其他任何当地媒体也没有能力进行调查。当没有报纸去深入挖掘腐败和渎职的故事时，会发生什么？和全国数百万的人一样，丹佛的居民出于看似完全合理的理由，决定不订阅当地的报纸。他们很忙，新闻令人沮丧，报纸很贵，但这些作为消费者的理性选择，最终却给他们作为纳税人和公民带来了严重的后果。请继续收听。多年前我看到过一张图表，它深深地印在我的脑海里，以至于我把它别在了办公室的墙上。
It has a red line and a blue line. The red represents newspaper advertising revenue. The blue shows the number of newspaper reporters in the country. From 1980 to the early 2000s, ad revenue, the red line, rose and rose and rose. It peaked in the early 2000s. Then there was a cliff. As people cancelled subscriptions and advertising revenue plummeted, so did the number of reporters, the blue line. Between 2006 and 2014, some 20,000 newspaper journalists lost their jobs. Now you can say, this is how capitalism works. Industry shrink, others grow. But is it possible that newspapers don't fit neatly into this economic model?
上面有一条红线和一条蓝线。红线代表报纸的广告收入。蓝线显示的是全国报纸记者的数量。从1980年到2000年代初，广告收入（即红线）不断攀升。它在2000年代初达到了顶峰。然后出现了一道悬崖。随着人们取消订阅和广告收入暴跌，记者人数（即蓝线）也随之骤降。2006年至2014年间，大约有2万名报纸记者失去了工作。现在你可以说，这就是资本主义的运作方式。某些行业萎缩，另一些行业增长。但有没有可能，报纸并不完全契合这种经济模型？
That they have a different kind of effect on their communities. Finance professors Paul Gao, Dermot Murphy and Chang Lee were thinking about the effect of newspaper shutting down when they spotted something on YouTube. We were watching this segment from this TV show called last week tonight with John Oliver about the state of the local newspaper in the United States. This is Dermot Murphy. John Oliver was explaining what Americans lose when newspapers disappear. Watch how often TV news ends up citing print sources.
它们对自己的社区有着不同类型的影响。金融学教授保罗·高（Paul Gao）、德莫特·墨菲（Dermot Murphy）和张力（Chang Lee）在YouTube上看到一些内容时，开始思考报纸倒闭的影响。我们当时在看电视节目《约翰·奥利弗上周今夜秀》中关于美国地方报纸现状的一个片段。说话的是德莫特·墨菲。约翰·奥利弗在解释当报纸消失时，美国人失去了什么。看看电视新闻引用印刷媒体来源的频率有多高。
According to the Chicago Tribune? According to the Detroit Free Press. According to the San Francisco Chronicle. According to the Times Picky Un. The Boston Globe Free Press. According to the San Francisco Chronicle. According to the Timespicking Un. The Boston Globe. The Orlando Sentinel. The Philadelphia Inquiry. The Pittsburgh Tribune Review.
根据《芝加哥论坛报》？根据《底特律自由报》。根据《旧金山纪事报》。根据《皮尤时报》。《波士顿环球报》自由报。《旧金山纪事报》。根据《皮尤时报》。《波士顿环球报》。《奥兰多哨兵报》。《费城问询报》。《匹兹堡论坛评论报》。
The Detroit News. And the Houston Chronicle reports. The Los Angeles Times reports. The Oklahoma reports. The Hartford Current reports. The Salt Lake Tribune reports. It's pretty obvious. Without newspapers around to sight, TV news would just be
《底特律新闻报》。以及《休斯顿纪事报》的报道。《洛杉矶时报》的报道。《俄克拉荷马报》的报道。《哈特福德信使报》的报道。《盐湖城论坛报》的报道。这显而易见。如果没有报纸供其引用，电视新闻就只剩下
Wolf Blitzer endlessly batting a ball of yarn around. So, as finance professors, we thought it would be important to look at the effective newspaper closures on local communities from the finance angle. The researchers had a hunch that the loss of newspaper jobs could affect municipal finance. Now, that sounds wonky, but let me explain why this is actually a big deal. Just as you borrow money from a bank to buy a house, towns and cities borrow money to build police stations, senior centers, and bridges. Taxpayers pay off these loans over time, just as homeowners pay off their mortgages.
沃尔夫·布利策（Wolf Blitzer）无休止地拨弄着一团毛线。因此，作为金融学教授，我们认为从金融角度审视报纸倒闭对当地社区的影响非常重要。研究人员有一种直觉，即报纸工作岗位的流失可能会影响市政财政。这听听起来可能很枯燥，但让我来解释一下为什么这其实是个大问题。就像你向银行借钱买房一样，城镇和城市借钱来建造警察局、高级中心和桥梁。纳税人随着时间推移偿还这些贷款，就像房主偿还抵押贷款一样。
Durma thought they might be a relationship between the cost of loans to cities and towns and disappearing newspapers. The researchers tallied every time a newspaper shut down between 1996 and 2015. They found 200 counties across the United States where there was a decline in the number of newspapers. They compared these counties to similar counties in the same state when newspapers were thriving. Once we had this information collected, we were able to see basically how government borrowing
德莫特认为，城镇的贷款成本与正在消亡的报纸之间可能存在某种关系。研究人员统计了1996年至2015年间每一家倒闭的报纸。他们发现在全美范围内，有200个县的报纸数量出现下降。他们将这些县与报纸蓬勃发展的同州类似县进行了比较。一旦我们收集到这些信息，我们基本上就能看出在报纸倒闭后，政府的借贷成本在长期内是如何增加的。
costs increase in the longer run after a newspaper closure. Dermot and his colleagues found that when a newspaper closed, the cost of loans in its county went up. This happened all over the country, including in Denver, home of the now closed Rocky Mountain News. Dermott says, one deceptively tiny number tells a significant story. In the long run, after a newspaper closes,
德莫特和他的同事们发现，当一家报纸倒闭时，其所在县的贷款成本就会上升。这种情况在全国各地都有发生，包括丹佛——现已倒闭的《落基山新闻报》的所在地。德莫特说，一个看似微不足道的数字讲述了一个重大的故事。从长远来看，在报纸倒闭后，
the borrowing cost for governments increases by about 0.1%. Now, the interest rate on a loan increasing from say 3% to 3.1% may not sound like much. But here's how it adds up. On average, a loan for $65 million in our sample. If the cost of a loan goes up by 0.1%,
政府的借贷成本增加了大约0.1%。现在，贷款利率从比方说3%上升到3.1%，听起来可能不算什么。但它是这样累积起来的。在我们样本中，平均一笔贷款为6500万美元。如果贷款成本上升0.1%，
that's about $65,000 more that taxpayers have to pay. $65,000 more every year. If the life of a loan is 10 years, that's about $650,000. And that's just for one loan. Cities and towns often have many loans like this. If a city has five projects, that's more than $3 million. If it has 50 projects, it's more than $30 million. That it has 50 projects, it's more than 30 million dollars. That does add up to real costs for the taxpayer. The effect showed up even after the researchers controlled for population growth and differences in local economies. It affected areas that were booming and areas that were shrinking.
这意味着纳税人必须多支付大约65,000美元。每年多支付65,000美元。如果贷款期限是10年，那就是大约65万美元。而这仅仅是一笔贷款。城市和城镇往往有很多这样的贷款。如果一个城市有五个项目，那就是300多万美元。如果它有50项目，那就是3000多万美元。如果它有50个项目，那将超过3000万美元。这确实给纳税人带来了真正的成本。即使在研究人员控制了人口增长和地方经济差异等因素后，这种影响依然存在。它既影响了经济繁荣的地区，也影响了经济萎缩的地区。
Dermot things that borrowing costs go up because something important disappears when newspapers close. The Watchdog channel. The Watchdog role that journalists play in holding public officials and powerful corporations accountable. When a newspaper closes or slashes its reporting staff, there's no one to play that role anymore. It's like getting rid of the police officers who patrol neighborhoods. Elected officials appear to know this. With the Denver Post announced cuts in 2018, this report popped up in the news. Another lawmakers joked about the cuts saying, hey, that means we can do whatever we want.
德莫特认为借贷成本上升是因为当报纸倒闭时，某种重要的东西消失了。看门狗频道。记者在追究公职人员和强大企业责任方面所扮演的看门狗角色。当报纸倒闭或大幅削减报道人员时，就不再有人扮演这个角色了。这就像解雇了在社区巡逻的警官一样。民选官员似乎也意识到了这一点。2018年《丹佛邮报》宣布裁员时，新闻界爆出了这样一条报道。另一位议员拿裁员开玩笑说：“嘿，这意味着我们可以为所欲为。”
Because fewer of the newspapers resources may go to the watchdog role of covering lawmakers at the Capitol. Dermot thinks the absence of watchdogs affects loan prices because banks realize their loans to local governments are now a little more risky. They know that some government officials will now be a little less honest, a little less careful. Lenders are a little more nervous about lending to such a government, and so when a lender is more nervous about lending to an inefficient government. And so when a lender is more nervous about lending to an inefficient government, then they're going to have to ask for a higher interest rate
因为报纸的更多资源可能不会用于在国会大厦报道议员的看门狗角色。德莫特认为，没有了看门狗会影响贷款价格，因为银行意识到他们对地方政府的贷款现在风险稍微大了一些。他们知道，一些政府官员现在会变得不那么诚实、不那么谨慎。贷款机构对于向这样的政府放贷会更加紧张，因此，当贷款机构对向效率低下的政府放贷感到更加紧张时，他们就会要求更高的利率
on the money they're lending to compensate for that risk. John Oliver had a similar theory, but he put it a little differently. Not having reporters at government meetings is like a teacher leaving her room of seventh graders to supervise themselves. Best case scenario, Brittany gets gum in her hair. Worst case scenario, you no longer have a school!
来补偿他们所借资金的风险。约翰·奥利弗也有类似的理论，但他表达的方式略有不同。政府会议上没有记者，就像老师离开教室让七年级学生自己管自己一样。最好的情况是，布兰妮头发上粘了口香糖；最坏的情况是，你们连学校都没了！
I-I look... You might be thinking here, okay, a lot of newspapers have closed, but there are now so many online publications. But these outlets do not appear to be an adequate replacement for a strong local newspaper. They are like having a community neighborhood watch. It's a wonderful compliment to a police department, but it's not a replacement for a police department.
我……你看……你可能会想，好吧，很多报纸都倒闭了，但现在有这么多的网络出版物。但这些媒体似乎并不能充分替代一份强有力的地方报纸。它们就像是社区的守望相助。它是对警察局的一个极好的补充，但它不能替代警察局。
If the internet is filling in the gap left to buy local newspaper closures, then we wouldn't see borrowing costs to go up like they are. We could even see them go down. At the state and local level, it's America's regional newspapers that are collapsing, they're imploding faster. That means David Simon used to be a reporter at the Baltimore Sun. He also created the TV series The Wire. About a decade ago, he made a diet prediction as newspaper after newspaper, laid off reporters.
如果互联网正在填补地方报纸倒闭留下的空白，那么我们就不会看到借贷成本像现在这样上升。我们甚至可能会看到它们下降。在州和地方层面，崩溃的是美国的区域性报纸，它们的内爆速度更快。这意味着大卫·西蒙曾是《巴尔的摩太阳报》的记者。他还创作了电视剧《火线》。大约十年前，随着一家又一家报纸裁掉记者，他做出了一个严峻的预测。
He testified before the US Senate and said that online publications were not going to cover goings on at City Hall and in state government. That means that all of a sudden there's nobody covering the cop shop, nobody covering the zoning board. The day I run into a Huffington Post reporter at a Baltimore zoning board hearing is the day that I will be confident that we've actually reached some sort of equilibrium. The next 10 or 15 years in this country are going to be a halcyon error for state and local political corruption.
他在美国参议院作证时表示，网络出版物不会去报道市政厅和州政府的动态。这意味着突然之间没有人去报道警察局，没有人去报道分区委员会。我偶遇《赫芬顿邮报》记者在巴尔的摩分区委员会听证会上出现的那一天，就是我确信我们实际上已经达到某种平衡的那一天。未来10到15年，这个国家将是州和地方政治腐败的黄金时代。
It is going to be one of the great times to be a corrupt politician. Legislators laughed, but David Simon was serious. He predicted that closing newspapers would lead to more corruption. We can see hints of this in Denver. While we can't know what would have happened if the Rocky was still around, some stories of corruption and wrongdoing might have surfaced earlier if there were reporters to keep an eye on things. Roger's believes she was fired for being a whistleblower, helping her friend Michelle
这将成为当一个腐败政客的最好时代之一。立法者们笑了，但大卫·西蒙是认真的。他预测报纸的倒闭将导致更多的腐败。我们可以在丹佛看到这方面的蛛丝马迹。虽然我们无法知道如果《落基山新闻报》仍然存在会发生什么，但如果有记者盯着事情，一些关于腐败和不当行为的故事可能会更早浮出水面。罗杰斯相信她是因为当了吹哨人而被解雇的，她曾帮她的朋友米歇尔·
Edwardson, an animal control officer, write a complaint about then-chief of police, John Patterson. The law... We uncovered the DHS case worker, Rochana Madera, who was assigned to the case, never met with the family to make sure the baby was safe. And then she lied about it. 60 days later, Natalie was dead. Remember, these are the stories that did get out eventually.
爱德华森（动物管制官）写了一份针对时任警察局长约翰·帕特森的投诉。法律……我们发现被指派负责此案的社会服务局（DHS）案情工作人员罗查娜·马德拉（Rochana Madera）从未与该家庭会面以确保婴儿的安全。然后她还对此撒了谎。60天后，娜塔莉死了。记住，这些是最终确实被曝光的故事。
We don't know what stories didn't make it out. While Dermott study looked at the financial effects of newspaper closures, you can imagine all kinds of other things that are affected when a newspaper closes. Public health, the environment, political engagement. It's this last area that Stanford economist Matthew Jensko has studied. He has examined how newspapers, prior to the advent of radio and TV, affected voter turnout. We find that there are large positive effects of newspaper entry on turnout.
我们不知道有哪些故事没能曝光。虽然德莫特的研究着眼于报纸倒闭的财务影响，但你可以想象当报纸倒闭时，所有其他类型的事情都会受到影响。公共卫生、环境、政治参与。斯坦福大学经济学家马修·詹斯科（Matthew Gentzkow）研究的正是最后这个领域。他考察了在广播和电视出现之前，报纸是如何影响选民投票率的。我们发现，报纸的进入对投票率有着巨大的积极影响。
So if you look at places where a newspaper entered, turnout increases in the following election. If you look at a place where a newspaper exited, turnout falls in the following election. Matthew and his co-authors wanted to see if the results changed, once radio and TV entered the picture. The pattern is kind of interesting. I think what you see is that the role of newspapers
因此，如果你看看有报纸进驻的地方，接下来的选举中投票率就会上升。如果你看看报纸撤出的地方，接下来的选举中投票率就会下降。马修和他的合著者想要看看一旦广播和电视进入大众视野，这些结果是否会改变。这种模式有点意思。我认为你所看到的是，报纸
in driving presidential election turnout gets smaller, as you might expect, given that now you no longer have to depend on newspapers. There are lots of other sources. Whereas the role of newspapers in driving congressional election turnout, local election turnout, or state level, turnout remains large throughout that period.
在推动总统选举投票率方面的作用变小了，正如你所预料的那样，既然现在你不再需要依赖报纸了。还有很多其他的来源。而报纸在推动国会选举投票率、地方选举投票率或州级投票率方面的作用在整个时期内依然很大。
The reason? If you want to learn about the presidential election, you won't have trouble finding information on cable TV. But those national sources are not going to help you learn what's happening in your state, or county, or city. If you're trying to learn about the local congressional race in a particular district in Kansas, you can't learn anything about that from watching CNN. You can't learn anything about that from watching Fox News. And so the local newspaper in that part of Kansas
原因何在？如果你想了解总统选举，你在有线电视上找信息绝不会有困难。但那些国家级的信息源不会帮你了解你的州、县或城市正在发生的事情。如果你试图了解堪萨斯州某个特定选区的当地国会竞选，你无法通过看CNN了解到任何情况。你无法通过看福克斯新闻（Fox News）了解到任何情况。因此，堪萨斯州那一地区的地方报纸
is likely to be reporting a bunch of information about those races that is not reported almost anywhere else. Matthew says local papers, they remain incredibly important and unique in many, many places in terms of coverage of local politics and local elections. It is local papers that have been decimated over the past two decades, and turnout in local elections looks no better. Portland State University found that in 10 of America's 30 largest cities, few are then 15% of voters turned out to vote for mayor. Let me repeat that. Few are then 15%. That makes turnout in the 2016 presidential election, 61% of eligible voters, seems
可能会报道大量关于这些竞选的信息，而这些信息在几乎其他任何地方都不会被报道。马修说，在报道地方政治和地方选举方面，地方报纸在很多很多地方仍然极其重要且独特。正是地方报纸在过去二十年中遭到严重摧毁，地方选举的投票率看起来也没有好转。波特兰州立大学发现，在美国30个最大城市中的10个城市中，参与市长投票的选民甚至不到15%。让我再重复一遍。甚至不到15%。这使得2016年总统选举的投票率（占合格选民的61%）看起来
sky high. For a variety of reasons, some of which we might not understand, newspapers appear to be vital to the civic and financial health of their cities, just like public schools or libraries or fire departments. But unlike those other services, newspapers are also private entities that must succeed financially in order to survive. In some parts of the world, taxpayers finance public interest journalism in the same way they pay for national defense, highways, and police. But Laura Frank, the former investigative reporter at the Rocky, says it's a bad idea for
直冲云霄。由于种种原因，其中一些原因我们可能并不理解，报纸似乎对所在城市的公民和财政健康至关重要，就像公立学校、图书馆或消防部门一样。但与这些其他服务不同的是，报纸也是私营实体，必须在财务上取得成功才能生存。在世界某些地方，纳税人资助公共利益新闻业的方式就像他们支付国防、高速公路和警察费用一样。但是，《落基山新闻》的前调查记者劳拉·弗兰克说，对于...
newspapers to get money from the government. If a big part of the watchdog role that the Fourth of State has is making sure that different levels of government are operating in a healthy and good way, we can't be dependent on those same levels of government to fund what we're doing. Some newspapers are looking to individuals with deep pockets. Wealthy entrepreneurs have bought newspapers like The Washington Post and The Los Angeles Times. Each is seeing a sort of renaissance. They've hired dozens of journalists. There's also been growth in public radio. Many local stations are expanding coverage.
报纸从政府拿钱是个坏主意。如果第四权力的看门狗角色很大一部分是确保各级政府以健康良好的方式运作，我们就不能依赖这些相同的政府层级来资助我们正在做的事情。一些报纸正在寻找财力雄厚的个人。富有的企业家收购了《华盛顿邮报》和《洛杉矶时报》等报纸。每一家都在经历某种复兴。他们雇用了几十名记者。公共广播也在不断发展。许多当地电台正在扩大报道范围。
And then there are nonprofits. After the Rocky shutdown, Laura started her own journalism outlet. I wound up actually being given a fellowship at the University of Colorado. Ironically, the Scripps Fellowship, named for the same family that owned the Rocky. She used the script's money to create an organization called I News. And the I stood for Investigative. And the idea was that we would do investigative stories and share them with other newsrooms. And that's what we did.
然后还有非营利组织。在《落基山新闻报》倒闭后，劳拉创办了自己的新闻机构。我最终实际上在科罗拉多大学获得了一项研究员职位。具有讽刺意味的是，这个“斯克里普斯奖学金”正是以拥有《落基山新闻报》的同一个家族命名的。她用斯克里普斯的资金创立了一个名为“I News”的组织。“I”代表调查（Investigative）。我们的想法是做调查报道，并与其他新闻编辑室共享。这就是我们所做的。
Remember the story about E-Waste? The Laura never got to finish when she was at the Rocky? That was the first story. I put a reporter on the story who spoke Mandarin and using a couple of different databases, we were able to track a shipment of E-Waste from Colorado to Hong Kong, and our reporter was then able to confirm that this e-waste had been illegally exported. And that would have been an important story if we had stopped right there to say, you know, despite an ongoing federal investigation, illegal e-waste is still being exported to foreign nations. But we didn't stop there. We found that some of the same kinds of dangerous practices
还记得关于电子垃圾的故事吗？劳拉在《落基山新闻报》工作时没能完成的那篇报道？那是第一个故事。我让一名会说普通话的记者跟进这个报道，通过几个不同的数据库，我们得以追踪一批从科罗拉多州运往香港的电子垃圾，我们的记者随后得以证实这批电子垃圾是被非法出口的。如果我们就在这里停下来，说“你看，尽管有联邦调查在进行，非法的电子垃圾仍在被出口到外国”，那这也算是一个重要的故事了。但我们没有就此打住。我们发现了一些与此相同的危险做法，
that were happening in China and Hong Kong, like dipping parts and acid and burning them over open flames, it was happening right here in Colorado, on a much smaller scale, but completely under the radar of state regulators. They had no idea it was happening. And so that would have been an important part of the story, They had no idea it was happening. And so that would have been an important part of the story,
那些在中国和香港发生的事情，比如把零件浸入酸液并在明火上焚烧，其实就发生在科罗拉多州这里，规模要小得多，但完全在州监管机构的雷达之外。他们根本不知道这正在发生。因此，这将是故事的重要部分，他们根本不知道这正在发生。因此，这将是故事的重要部分，
but we didn't stop there either. We found that most of Colorado's used electronic waste was actually winding up in local dumps, instead of being recycled. And again, I feel like one of those commercials, but that's not all. We didn't stop there. We found much of the e-waste that was being illegally exported, locally dumped, or dipped
但我们也没有就此打住。我们发现，科罗拉多州的大多数旧电子垃圾实际上最终都流向了当地的垃圾场，而不是被回收利用。再说一次，我感觉自己像在拍商业广告，但还不止于此。我们没有就此打住。我们发现，许多被非法出口、本地倾倒，或者在科罗拉多州被浸泡
and burned in Colorado. And the SPAC Yards was actually coming from government surplus auctions. In fact, the very state agency responsible for regulating e-waste was sending its own trash electronics to auction. That is unbelievable. They shared their reporting with news outlets across Colorado. She dug into the story of what happens to old computers. For I News, it's a nonprofit investigative outfit in Denver.
和焚烧的电子垃圾。而这些旧货场实际上来自政府的盈余拍卖。事实上，负责监管电子垃圾的同一个州级机构正在把自己当成垃圾的电子产品送去拍卖。这简直难以置信。他们与科罗拉多州各地的媒体分享了他们的报道。她深入挖掘了旧电脑最终命运的故事。对于总部位于丹佛的非营利调查机构“I News”来说，
And she found it. Some of the government's trash computers wind up being shipped to developing nations, sent to the local dump, and even dismantled here in people's backyards and garages. The response was even greater than if the story had been published in just one newspaper. Because of the way we were approaching this in a collaborative way, instead of a competitive way, the story of Colorado's e-waste went from being a story that no media had the capacity to cover to a story that every major news outlet could share with their audience. It was in every daily paper. It was on television. It
她找到了。一些政府的垃圾电脑最终被运往发展中国家，送到当地垃圾场，甚至在这里人们的后院和车库里被拆解。反响甚至比故事只在一家报纸上发表时还要大。由于我们采用的是合作方式而不是竞争方式，科罗拉多州电子垃圾的故事从一个没有任何媒体有能力报道的故事，变成了一个所有主流媒体都能与他们的观众分享的故事。它登上了每一份日报。它上了电视。它
was on the radio. So suddenly we had this statewide conversation about what was actually happening to Colorado's e-waste. And that had never happened before. And the state legislature then moved to close some of the loopholes that were allowing this to happen. So that's the way the Fourth Estate in a democracy is supposed to work. This is clearly a success story.
上了广播。因此，突然之间，我们有了关于科罗拉多州电子垃圾实际情况的全州范围的对话。这以前从未发生过。随后，州立法机关采取行动，堵住了允许这种情况发生的某些漏洞。这就是民主社会中第四权力应该发挥作用的方式。这显然是一个成功的故事。
Laura lost her job at the Rocky, but that led her to set up I News. She got stories like the e-waste investigation out to the public. The government made changes to the program in response. But Laura still thinks there is an immense cost when a newspaper closes. It took two years for us to get the story out. So how many children were exposed and wound up with high levels of lead in their blood
劳拉失去了在《落基山新闻报》的工作，但这促使她创立了“I News”。她把像电子垃圾调查这样的报道公之于众。政府对该计划做出了回应并进行了修改。但劳拉仍然认为，当报纸倒闭时，付出的代价是巨大的。我们花了两年时间才把这个故事报道出来。那么，有多少儿童在
while we were trying to figure out a way to get the story out? Yes, I think when there's a really important story that a journalist somehow finds out about, it will eventually get out, but my God, who was harmed while we waited. And those are only the stories we know are going untold. It's the unknown, unknown that is also very worrisome to me. One of the bedrock assumptions of economics is that when individuals behave rationally, good things happen to them. Good things happen to their communities, their society. The invisible hand of the market takes all of our rational selfish decisions and produces a society that flourishes. Much of the time, this does
我们试图找出报道这个故事的方法时，受到了接触并导致血液中铅含量超标？是的，我认为当发生一个记者不知怎么发现的真正重要故事时，它最终总会曝光，但天哪，在我们等待的过程中，谁受到了伤害。而这些还只是那些最终得以曝光的故事。那些未知的、未被报道的故事同样让我非常担忧。经济学的基本假设之一是，当个人表现得理性时，好事就会降临到他们身上。好事会降临到他们的社区、他们的社会。市场无形的手把我们所有理性的自私决定汇聚在一起，创造出一个蓬勃发展的社会。大多数时候，这确实
work. But it turns out that for things like police departments, public schools, and newspapers, the logic of the market doesn't produce the outcomes we want to see. We can all end up paying more when we all try individually to pay less. Many experts have tried to think of ways communities can solve problems that market forces don't solve on their own. How do you get people to pitch in even when it's in their rational self-interest, to free-ride off of others?
行之有效。但事实证明，对于警察局、公立学校和报纸这样的事物来说，市场的逻辑并没有产生我们想要看到的结果。当我们每个人都试图在个人层面上少花钱时，我们最终可能会付出更多。许多专家一直在思考社区如何解决市场力量无法自行解决的问题。你如何让人们即使在符合其理性自私利益的情况下也愿意出力，去搭别人的便车？
These solutions begin with the same insight. Sometimes, when you try and pinch pennies, you end up paying in pounds. This episode was produced by Raina Cohen and edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Path Shah, Thomas Liu, Laura Correll, Kat Schuchnacht, and Lu Sheikwaba. Special thanks to producer Meredith Turk for getting us the voices of the Denver residents you heard at the top of the show and to Andy Huthur for his engineering help.
这些解决方案都始于同一个洞察。有时，当你试图在微小的事情上省钱时，你最终会在大钱上付出代价。本集节目由雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）制作，塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）编辑。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、帕思·沙阿（Path Shah）、托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）、劳拉·科雷尔（Laura Correll）、卡特·舒赫纳特（Kat Schuchnacht）和卢·谢克瓦巴（Lu Sheikwaba）。特别感谢制作人梅雷迪思·特克（Meredith Turk）为我们带来了节目开头听到的丹佛居民的声音，以及安迪·胡瑟（Andy Huthur）提供的工程技术帮助。
Hidden Brain has a request for you. We'd like to better understand who's listening and how you're using podcasts. Please help us out by completing a short, anonymous survey at npr.org slash podcast survey. It takes less than 10 minutes and really helps support the show. That's npr.org slash podcast survey. A Ran Sanghiro this week is a mentor of mine, Arlene Morgan. Arlene was an editor and recruiter at the Philadelphia Inquara, who took a chance on me some 25 years ago.
《隐藏的大脑》有一个请求。我们希望能更好地了解谁在收听以及你是如何使用播客的。请在 npr.org slash podcast survey 上完成一份简短的匿名调查来帮助我们。这只需要不到10分钟，并且对支持本节目真的很有帮助。网址是 npr.org slash podcast survey。本周的“赞赏桑希罗”是一位我的导师，阿琳·摩根（Arlene Morgan）。阿琳曾是《费城问询报》的编辑和招聘人员，大约25年前，她对我这个毛头小子寄予了信任。
She believed in great journalism and she also believed that in order to get great journalism, you need to invest in recruiting, training and developing a diverse pool of journalists. I owe the start of my career as a newspaper journalist to her. That work forms the foundation of what I do today at Hidden Brain. Thanks Arlene. You can find more Hidden Brain on Facebook and Twitter. If you like this show, please tell one friend about it. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
她坚信伟大新闻业的力量，她也坚信，为了获得伟大的新闻业，你需要投资于招聘、培训和培养多元化的记者群体。我作为一名报纸记者的职业生涯正是从她开始的。这些工作构成了我今天在《隐藏的大脑》中所做事情的基础。谢谢你，阿琳。你可以在脸书和推特上找到更多关于《隐藏的大脑》的内容。如果你喜欢这个节目，请告诉你的一个朋友。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。本集节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。